but that's the thing i don't i think
that a lot of the [ __ ] that i want to do
or i'll end up doing
you know with the right with the right
amount of hustle and determination and
blessings
it'll be something totally totally
obscure from telling jokes
because one of my goals is to just get
on one of those
shows to get in one of those spaces that
you would never imagine seeing me in
you know what i mean i'm gonna be the
first black dude to be the joker or some
[ __ ]
you know what i mean that's the type of
[ __ ] i'd be aiming for
tonight i'm going to kill the batman
like
i can see that i'm awesome [ __ ] man i
could see that yeah
wow we broke into carlos there we saw a
couple carlos
moments right now you're like loose whoa
straight straight
i didn't know man right now i didn't
know we were talking about deep [ __ ] you
asked me all these questions that
required like real answers and [ __ ]
well that i mean well you knew coming in
that you started the interview in that
mode because you knew what this was
right so we captured it man it's kind of
captured
it's captured man um before we get out
of here is there anything else you want
the world to know
um hey man this is the [ __ ] i've been on
anything is true if you believe it
okay anything is true if you believe
that [ __ ] so be careful what you out
here believe in
subscribe to some of your own [ __ ]
man what do you believe
i believe i'm a magnificent [ __ ]
every day
and every day she'll be full of
surprises
well i gotta say man after you coming
straight off the road
and this is kind of your transition day
you're doing shows all weekend
at uptown uptown comedy kona and the
fact you were willing to do this man
joe i like your hustle man you always on
you stay persistent
you stay grinding and you just refuse to
lose bro that's the whole mindset
like you were doing a whole one-man show
bro
you get what i'm saying like you do all
this [ __ ] yourself that's the grime man
that's the grind just stay on that [ __ ]
stay posting your [ __ ] somebody in the
comments [ __ ] with your [ __ ] so hard
they want to be a part of what you doing
they want to hold the camera they want
to be in the room they want to ride with
you
you'll start seeing people just
volunteer to [ __ ] with you when they see
that you
when you got that mindset that you got
that refused to lose [ __ ] yeah
that draws people to you and they make
them want to help you win
that's why you shouldn't be afraid to
ask for what you want
put it out there a lot of times as
entertainers we get put into a box when
we get afraid to ask for things
like don't be afraid to ask people to
help you
that's another one and let people do
what they do bro
let the cameraman be the cameraman let
the sound do be the sound dude
let people be who let them be who they
are bro
don't nobody like to be ran
find somebody you believe in that you
don't have to tell to do the [ __ ]
cause they see it like you see it you
get what i'm saying
yeah i found a lot of those connections
also happen organically that's what it
is just kind of they just kind of flow
into your life
and you just kind of hop on the the raft
together you have to
because you know the saying is if you
want to go fast
go alone you want to go far take your
friends
carlos miller yep my man
i've been reading this [ __ ] i told you i
was gonna [ __ ] their minds up
yeah i wasn't ready for that i know i
was just gonna be hey man how's it been
going you're like yo
listen to me man hey man we're writing a
book water is wet and the eagles are dry
what the [ __ ] is he saying
i might have been rambling but bro i
just i had to share that [ __ ] with you
all i know you got some audience out
there bruh
that's what it's going to do let them
know that's what it's all about jonah's
brick by brick bro
yeah break by brick and i i had gone
through a little bit of self-doubt
over like the past week or so no but
this is this is definitely i've had a
couple good
moments just to eliminate all self-doubt
just
don't never doubt yourself take all the
negative [ __ ] out bro if you just tell
yourself i'm the [ __ ]
every day and don't don't accept nothing
else
it's the old jeezy line and say i'm the
[ __ ] and if i ain't y'all let me think
what i think
like don't change my mind about me being
the [ __ ]
laugh at your problems handle them
but don't never let the [ __ ]
handle you like don't ever be up
stressing about some [ __ ] you either can
do it or you can't
why would you kill yourself worrying
about some [ __ ] that you can't change
you just gotta figure out what the [ __ ]
you can do man
and that skills and what you're what
people like about you and then just
go with that the whole way yeah that's
your money
anything that you can do better than
everybody else cash in on it
if you're at a job right now that you
[ __ ] hate and you know that you got
the best handwriting in that [ __ ] bro
find a way to write some letters do
something i'm just saying man
it might be ten dollars a weekend but
i'm telling you you can capitalize off
anything that you better than everybody
else at
and there's room for everyone it is room
for
everyone bro everybody
even the dopest [ __ ] is looking
for an assistant
to be the second dopest [ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm saying like
that's the whole [ __ ] in the game bro
drake is drake right but look what he
did when he jumped on the migo track
he brought the migos to the forefront
and they never left because they was
dope
they were like i'm dope but this is dope
to me
so i'm i'm gonna validate the dope even
if this does nothing
i [ __ ] with this because because i [ __ ]
with this you get what i'm saying
yeah because some people go up like a
bottle rocket yeah
it's just like like you said cause they
they weren't actually
they weren't real sometimes your
blessing is to be the blessing bro
you might not be the rapper that's gonna
blow up and be the next lil wayne
but you might be the person who gave him
the opportunity to be the next lil wayne
you might find the next one that whole
tupac
[ __ ] you would be the mind that sparked
the change that changed the game
just because you use what you have and
you open your [ __ ] up to somebody else
you know what i'm saying share that [ __ ]
find the dopeness get around it fight
get around people that inspire you
because it all goes back to your team
what you put you around the most that's
what you gon that's what you attract
if you around a whole bunch of dope
[ __ ] she the coldest model
he the coldest photographer your homeboy
is the dopest director
to you and you see how good they are
like respect the creatives
that don't have to be that's not already
on that level
see that [ __ ] believe in other people
too because that's how you grow your
talent your blessing
yeah i heard issa ray say like everybody
wants to reach
up and try to work with people that are
already there she's like reach across
exactly reach across bro you you'd be
surprised who you running back into
that dude who telling you the pa dude
who just go get the coffee and
make sure everybody get in the car five
years you're pulling up is his
production
he the director or he the producer or he
the ep
or he was he he had enough juice to say
hey call my man carlos miller he'd be
perfect for this
you hear what i'm saying like you never
know what people can [ __ ] do for you
in the future just by cultivating and
establishing real relationships
not because you want something just
because they're reaching across and your
dopeness validates their dopeness
they help these people find you so now
these people want to give them a
permanent
you know what i'm saying is to look out
without looking
you sometimes throw me a no-look pass
that's it
throw me to no look that's it carlos
miller thanks for being on hot breath my
man
my man hey hot brother and sister if you
love comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips